nouveau tutoriel aujourd'hui avec
toujours comme source le manuel
géographie 3e 6e des éditions de bouc
développement économique a été
progressivement distinguer de la seule
croissance économique en lien évident
avec celle ci le développement
économique s'accompagne d'évolution dans
la société
une nouvelle technologie pour les
productions agricoles et industrielles
transformation des structures politiques
institutionnelles nouveaux rapports
sociaux etc
c'est d'un processus qualitatif qui crée
plus d'interdépendance entre les
secteurs économiques et les catégories
sociales
pour rappel il y a deux grandes théories
du développement économique le courant
marxiste du courant libéral pour le
courant marxiste la voie du
développement économique se trouve dans
l'élimination des situations de blocage
les dominations comme les pays riches
qui domine fait ifo et dépendances un
pays qui doit importer des ressources
indispensables ou des désarticulation
exemple les régions d'un pays qui ont
peu de relations entraînent ce courant a
eu comme conséquence l'apparition de
mouvements révolutionnaires qui avait
pour objectif de libérer la population
de ces blocages la révolution cubaine en
est un exemple pour le courant libéral
la sortie de la situation de sous
développement correspond à l'insertion
de l'économie du pays dans les échanges
mondiaux en se basant sur des avantages
comparatifs les avantages comparatifs
sont les avantages qu'un pays a par
rapport à d'autres par exemple un coup
de main d'oeuvre moins élevés la plupart
des pays émergents comme les dragons
asiatiques depuis des années 1990 la
chine la chine aujourd'hui mais aussi le
mexique ou le brésil ont adopté ce
modèle pour s'insérer dans l'économie
mondiale et connaître une période de
forte croissance comme dans cette vidéo
nous allons nous focaliser sur cinq
facteurs qui vont amener ce
développement économique
l'autosuffisance alimentaire
l'investissement humain le rôle de
l'état la diminution de la croissance de
la population et l'ouverture au marché
mondial
en ce qui concerne l'autosuffisance
alimentaire le développement de
l'agriculture vivrière est cruciale non
seulement parce que celle ci doit
fournir l'alimentation à leur vue
nécessaire à l'investissement mais parce
que son développement est vite un
surcroît de chômage et une trop grande
dépendance alimentaire par rapport aux
pays développés
les réformes agraires ont souvent joué
un rôle important dans l'augmentation
des robes des rendements notamment en
asie à taiwan par exemple l'état a
racheté aux grands propriétaires leurs
terres et les a revendues aux métayers
les métiers sont des exploitants
agricoles qui loue une terre le loyer
est payé en nature c'est-à-dire une
partie de la récolte est donné au
propriétaire du terrain
l'épargné ainsi constitué a été investi
dans la gamme l'industrie aujourd'hui 90
% des agriculteurs possèdent la terre
qu'ils travaillent et les rendements à
l'hectare sont très supérieurs à la
moyenne mondiale
la propagation de la révolution verte
qui est en fait une modification des
techniques agricoles qui permettent
d'augmenter les rendements comme par
exemple la sélection de semences ou des
engrais ou l'apparition des pesticides
cette révolution verte a permis
d'augmenter les rendements agricoles
aujourd'hui de nouvelles techniques
apparaissent tout aussi performante mais
plus écologique et moins consommatrice
d'engrais de pesticides
ce qui permet au paysan d'être moins
dépendant des marchands un taux de
croissance élevé de la population entre
3 et 4% par exemple annuler les effets
de la croissance économique
une réduction de la croissance de la
population permet d'augmenter le niveau
de vie moyen de la population avec un
taux de croissance économique identique
mais l'amélioration du niveau de vie et
l'éducation des femmes sont les
conditions pour permettre une meilleure
planification familiale on peut dès lors
se demander si la diminution de la
croissance de la population est une
condition ou une conséquence du
développement économique
le fait d'avoir terminé sa transition
démographique bien sûr est donc une
condition du développement pour les pays
du sud
l'investissement dans l'éducation et la
formation de la population est
fondamentale puisque les entreprises
recherchent une main de former et
qualifier cette éducation joue également
un rôle important au niveau social
surtout pour les femmes puisqu'elle leur
permet généralement un meilleur planning
familial l'alphabétisation et
l'éducation de la population sont donc
des axes prioritaires du développement
l'histoire a clairement montré la
supériorité de l'économie de marché sur
la planification centralisée
autrement dit
une économie d'inspiration communiste
elle a également révélé la nécessité
d'une intervention de l'état qui doit
créer non seulement le contexte un tissu
institutionnel et juridique
indispensable à l'économie de marché
il faut des règles mais aussi les
instruments de politiques budgétaires
monétaires industriel favorable
développement économique la stabilité
politique et la cohésion sociale sont
deux conditions du développement
économique sans stabilité politique et
sans cohésion sociale point de
développement économique
mais face à la mondialisation et aux
grandes puissances multinationales comme
par exemple google mais dans d'autres
secteurs mosanto le rôle d état
sera-t-il encore suffisant pour garantir
les conditions d'un développement
harmonieux
ou bien le marché international
sera-t-il le seul élément régulateur aux
risques et périls des populations enfin
la dernière priorité est la rupture de
l'isolément comme l'ont montré les pays
d'asie du sud est
le dr le processus du développement
économique ne peut se réaliser
aujourd'hui à l'écart du marché mondial
mais ce processus pose le problème de la
dépendance au marché mondial
s'il doit s'ouvrir au marché mondial les
pays du sud ne peuvent éviter un certain
protectionnisme
sinon leur consommateur risque d'acheter
massivement des produits importés au
détriment de l'activité économique
locale
le protectionnisme est une politique de
protection de la production nationale
contre la concurrence étrangère
étrangères notamment par des mesures
douanières les produits importés
donc les produits achetés à l'étranger
coûteront plus cher que les produits
produits sur le territoire national la
croissance économique augmente la
richesse d'un pays
cependant le degré de satisfaction des
besoins humains essentiels comme se
nourrir se loger se former dépend de la
répartition de cette richesse entre les
personnes il n'existe pas de lien
automatique entre la croissance
économique du pib et le développement
humain c'est-à-dire l'idée h
il existe néanmoins des éléments clés
qui peuvent contribuer à créer une
dynamique entre les bus le rôle de
l'état qui va répartir et des
redistribuer la richesse le souci de
combattre les
égalité la défense des valeurs de
solidarité et c'est par la politique
qu'il mène les pays différents diffèrent
par leur capacité à transformer
l'augmentation de la richesse en
développement humain nous voici arrivés
au terme de cette vidéo consacrée aux
facteurs du développement comme vous en
avez pris l'habitude j'espère que la
prise de note a été efficace que vous
avez noté vos questions éventuelles et
que vous n'oubliez pas de répondre au
questionnaire qui permettra de vérifier
l'acquisition des différents savoirs
utiles à la poursuite de nos activités
en classe
je vous souhaite une bonne fin de
journée et à bientôt